[Music]
rapper Kanye West has been back on
Twitter for less than two weeks and he's
already brought this social media
company to its knees in an epic four day
rampage through cyberspace West has
endorsed pundit Candace Owens the
pro-trump pundit Candice Owens shared
videos by Scott Adams posted a
photograph of himself in a make America
great again hat and earns two retweets
from the President of the United States
well progressives are almost unconscious
with rage Rolling Stone magazine calls
West's tweet quote a real threat they
don't say what it's a real threat too
but they clearly mean it author and
columnist mark Stein knows what it's a
threat too and he joins us tonight mark
what what what are kanye west tweets a
threat to would you say well they're a
threat to the lock-step a homogeneity of
popular culture in the United States
and to a certain extent I'm not
unsympathetic to that you know some
people mocking us conservatives because
we're such squaresville dario's that
when some groovy hepcat that all the
beatniks dig like kanye west comes on we
all get so excited that the you know
we're thrilled that easy he's looking at
us we're the square frumpy Wallflower at
the prom and he's given us the eye and
to be honest I quite like the fact that
the right has been celebrity I mean I
remember in the 2000 election going to
the Republican convention and being
given the folder showing which
celebrities were supporting george w
bush and when I say folder it was an
attractive piece of letter size paper
with two names on one side there was Pat
Boone and one of the Oakridge boys I
can't remember which Oak Ridge boy
that's nine of them I think there's nine
of them seven of them
Democrats once a green but whichever
Oakridge where it was with supporting
George W wood and I think and there was
something terribly refreshing having
nope in having no purchase on pop
culture but the fact the fact is we're
not really excited it's not so much the
excitement from our end it's the fact
that Kanye at his end is sick of being
told what to think he that the box is
that the left has built for its
celebrity supporters are getting smaller
and smaller and smaller and a
self-respecting man like this guy is it
doesn't want to be put in that box and
we just wants to bust out of that box
we are you saying that art is not the
same thing as conformity I am normally
enough it's strange to me because the
art is always good then what we've got
all about how transgressive we are they
are we need we need transgressive
artists to bust the bounds of this and
bust the bounds of that and then they
demand that all the transgressive
artists march in lockstep with the
approved ideology now I will say this
Tucker that I think this is in a way a
sort of obvious correction Trump is a
showbiz figure he did beauty pageants
and he did a reality show he's on the
Regis Philbin Christmas album firing
Blitzen and hiring Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer now I would have I would have
voted for president Philbin if I could
but the guy who's on the Regis Philbin
Christmas album is a pretty good second
place and if you think about it from
Kanye's point of view if he walks into a
room and there's Chuck Schumer and
there's Elizabeth Warren and over in the
other corner is Donald Trump who is
Kanye going to go and talk to him it's
he's gonna go and talk to Trump this is
in a sense is a natural correction to
the insanity that the celebrity left has
maintained since November 26 but that's
that's one of the reasons they've always
hated Trump because he's so off-grid for
good and bad that he represented the
possibility of a real alignment and they
hate that is really that's a threat to
their business and so that's why they
shut down
all dissent or any affinity for him
needs to be punished immediately because
otherwise this could happen yeah and I
think they understand the Rolling Stone
piece is interesting to me because the
guy sounds as if he's really scared
the pop culture acts as the great
enforcer in in in America and everyone
knows that culture is upstream of
politics if you control pop culture the
politics will follow it's not the
Supreme Court you know when Anthony
Kennedy licenses gay marriage he's just
saying that the pop culture has told him
to get on side in effect it's bigger
than anything so when for example Shania
Twain a couple of days ago she gives an
interview to The Guardian saying that if
she'd been American she'd have voted for
Donald Trump immediately Shania is
plugged into a pulp and it's made to
apologize and back down and you know
then that's pathetic for Shania man I
feel like a woman man I feel like a
celebrity who has the guts to stand up
to this and I'm embarrassed for my
country that Shania Twain from Timmins
Ontario
god bless I didn't have the guts to do
what Kanye did and say get lost I think
for myself but I still like her Marx
died I made it thanks from stuff I
always learn something from this segment
I'm grateful to you for that thank you
even if even if it's only should i as
hometown now which is good to know
see ya [ __ ] stock up